[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the latest on a search warrant executed
in the tiger woods crash investigation
what information the so-called black box
could hold they'll have more information
they can attribute the cause of the of
the action ex-cop derek shovin's trial
in the death of george floyd is just
days away we asked famed criminal
defense attorney mark garagos will it be
a conviction or acquittal we've seen
this movie before plus hate crimes
towards asian americans are on the rise
we look into what steps law enforcement
is taking to combat it and a deeper dive
into the grand jury process after
rochester police officers are not
indicted for the daily i'm brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin
investigators in los angeles are digging
through the black blocks from tiger
woods suv analyzing the crash data
golfing great tiger woods is recovering
from surgery after suffering multiple
leg injuries from a rollover crash the
los angeles county sheriff's office says
woods was driving downhill on a winding
road last month in an area known as a
trouble spot for speeding and accidents
the sheriff's office says there was no
evidence of impairment and labeled it an
accident not a crime the following day
but detectives executed a search warrant
monday to collect the so-called black
box from the 2021 genesis suv woods was
driving the data could show the
vehicle's speed steering angle
acceleration and braking activity
the investigators in the accident
or in the in the collision they
they did a search warrant to seize in
essence the black box of the vehicle and
that's all it is
and they're uh going to go through it
and see if they can find out
what was the performance of vehicle what
was happening at the time of impact
and with that they'll have more
information they can attribute the cause
of the of the accident
and that's all it is
and we'll leave it at that
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and terry austin
gigi the more i read about this the more
i'm questioning the grounds for this
search warrant you don't use warrants to
determine if there was a crime this
sounds like a bit of a fishing
expedition what do you think
i completely agree with you you need
probable cause in order to get a search
warrant and in this case you know i'm
not sure there is any you even heard
officer villanueva in another uh
interview saying that the deputy on
scene found no evidence of impairment
tiger woods was lucid had no odor of
alcohol no evidence of narcotics in the
car this is just an
an accident so without any other
witnesses corroborating that he was
speeding or any other proof that the
tiger woods was committing a crime i'm
not sure what probable cause exists to
support a search warrant in this
yeah and
terry as you heard from gigi no belief
that uh tiger woods was under the
influence no order of alcohol so if
that's the case what's the worst case
scenario in terms of possible charges
for tiger woods
well that's right you know the police
said he was lucifer he was responsive he
was cooperating with the police at the
scene so at the end of the day if no
alcohol and no drugs were a factor then
he will probably not face criminal
charges and also you know if the black
box shows that he wasn't speeding or he
wasn't driving erratically then i think
they're going to categorize this as a
simple accident the only problem would
be if the black box shows that he was
speeding and even then brian he would
only get a speeding ticket so i think so
far based on what we've seen he's
probably okay right now exactly thank
you both
and now to other top news making
headlines at the law and crime network
a witness to a colorado murder trial has
been identified as a homicide victim 31
year old roxanne martinez was found dead
in denver after being called to testify
in the case against dante lucas lucas is
accused of murdering his pregnant
girlfriend in 2013. denver police say
the link between martinez's death and
her planned testimony appears to be
coincidental
a missing texas ten-year-old has been
found safe after her mother's murder
carrollton police issued an amber alert
for rosemary lee's singer and her father
ronald lee singer earlier this week the
elder lee singer is accused of murdering
his ex-wife and daughter's mother maria
romero ramos police say an alert motel
employee spotted the singers and
reported their location 30 miles north
of dallas singer was arrested and is
charged with murder
still ahead on law and crime daily asian
american hate crimes on the rise and how
officials are responding to it but first
george floyd's legacy memorialized in a
bill from the house but will that have
any effect on the upcoming trial of the
former police officer derek shovin our
legal analysis next
[Music]
welcome back the first trial for one of
the ex-officers charged with murdering
george floyd is just days away and ahead
of it new legislation is making its way
through congress
the house passed the george floyd
justice and policing act late wednesday
night the bill which was presented by
congresswoman karen bass bans chokeholds
no knock warrants and drug cases and
incentivize state attorney generals to
investigate local police departments
george floyd's family was at the capitol
for the final vote
jury selection for the trial against
former police officer derrick chauvin
who was seen in a video kneeling on
floyd's neck before he died in 2020 is
set for monday
long crimes anjanet levy spoke with a
well-known defense attorney about the
difficulty of prosecuting police
officers for murder
yeah brian you know over the years we've
seen police officers put on trial some
of them have been convicted while others
have not veteran defense attorney mark
garagos says some are not convicted
because some jurors basically have a
hard time wrapping their heads around
the idea of sending a police officer to
prison
what i witnessed at the scene was 100
percent lapd policy 1991 in los angeles
four l.a police officers beat rodney
king during a traffic stop those
officers were acquitted in state court
does that case foreshadow what could
happen in the george floyd case defense
attorney mark garagos who gained
notoriety representing scott peterson in
the death of his wife lazy believe so
we've seen this movie before the
officers in rodney king were acquitted
because the
basically the case was moved to a
jurisdiction
or change a venue that was helpful to
them two of the four officers in the
king case were later convicted in
federal court of violating king's civil
rights here you've got the same thing at
least arguably starting to be set up if
you read what's been reported several
media outlets have reported a federal
grand jury is investigating floyd's
death as a backstop even with floyd's
death captured on videotape gary ghost
believes not guilty verdicts are
possible chauvin has got a tough tough
case i think
there is going to be it's going to be a
very difficult prosecution to make the
case against the other three officers
and especially two of the three who were
rookies there have been other cases
where the evidence appeared overwhelming
only to end in an acquittal in
cincinnati campus police officer ray
tensing's two trials for the shooting
death of sam dubose in 2015 ended in
hung juries and a judge later granted a
motion for acquittal a federal
investigation is underway in that case
but a jury also found chicago police
officer jason van dijk guilty of
second-degree murder in the 2014
shooting death of laquan mcdonald van
dyke is serving prison time for that
crime
everything will be under a microscope in
the chauvin case including the officer's
training and restraint techniques which
medical experts say caused floyd's death
minneapolis police had been trained in a
technique that includes placing a knee
on a person's neck it wasn't
destiny of derrick sheldon on george
floyd's neck for eight minutes and 46
seconds that killed him it was the knee
of the entire minneapolis police
department that killed george floyd
because they have a pattern and practice
of deliberate indifference to arrestees
especially uh young black men meanwhile
mark garagos believes derrick chauvin
will take the stand to try to explain
his actions they're going to be
testifying because cops almost
inevitably in these cases testify
because they're used to getting up on
the stand they're used to giving their
point of view
alan dershowitz calls it test a lie but
i won't go that far but i will tell you
that the cops will get up there they
will invoke officer safety
now derek shovin's lawyers are expected
to argue at trial that george floyd's
death was actually caused by him having
a powerful narcotic called fentanyl in
his system they're expected to say that
actually caused his death and not being
restrained the way he was on the ground
brian
thanks angenet back to discuss proposed
new legislation and the trial of derrick
shown for the murder of george floyd is
defense attorney gigi gonzalez and terry
austin terry i've seen these laws in new
york banning chokeholds in 93 didn't
save eric garner in 2014 and it didn't
bring an officer to justice without real
teeth to it this law kind of just sounds
like lip service in the memory of floyd
what do you think
you know what brian i couldn't agree
with you more look i hope that the law
passes on the federal level but we know
for a fact that many states and some
cities already have laws banning
chokeholds and it hasn't made a
difference you said it yourself in the
eric garner case the law was on the
books in new york for years and still
they use the method and i think the
point is until these officers are
personally held accountable
and personally in the criminal justice
system held accountable i don't think
we're going to see a difference because
they use the excuse that they thought
they were using reasonable force and
until they go to jail it's not going to
change i think the way these laws have
been implemented i agree now gigi show
his defense seems to be pretty clear as
angenette said the fentanyl killed him
is probably going to be defense perhaps
chauvin takes the stand maybe a lack of
intent or lack of knowledge argument or
pointing to his training what do you
think uh do you think that that will be
enough though to beat the charges
i don't think that's going to be enough
to beat the charges here um you know
especially when you have experts coming
out and saying that the actual cause of
death was compression to the neck and
back for eight minutes and 46 seconds by
derrick chauvin uh you know he's going
to have to take the stand and explain
why he did what he did and when he does
that he's going to have to tell the
jurors that he was
kneeling on george floyd's neck for
eight minutes and 46 seconds because
that was his job as a police officer and
he was doing what he was trained to do i
don't think that's going to be very
successful but it's really all he's got
yeah it's gonna explain why i wasn't put
in the recovery position as well and
jeanette is it possible that derek
chovan and the other officers facing
charges are working together
yeah mark garagos had kind of talked
about that on his podcast a couple of
weeks ago he said you know sometimes
defendants when they're charged in these
cases they will work together in what's
called a joint defense agreement now we
don't know if that's the case here but
it could be a possibility they may be
sharing information or tactics or even
depending on the case getting one
another to testify for the other so we
just have to wait and see makes sense if
derek shove and is found not guilty of
any of these charges or walks it's gonna
be a lot easier for the other three
officers thank you all for joining be
sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for gavel to gavel coverage of
strobin's trial starting march 8.
coming up on law and crime daily a grand
jury does not indict officers for the
death of daniel pruitt how new york
attorney general is trying to change the
grand jury process
plus asian and pacific islander
americans have been facing an uptick in
targeted crime find out how long the
trend has been going for and how the
coronavirus had made it worse next
[Music]
welcome back hate crimes against asian
americans are on the rise even as
overall hate crimes have declined
in new york a suspect is wanted for
punching a 56 year old asian male
rendering him unconscious in a separate
incident a 23 year old is facing second
degree murder charges for stabbing a man
in the back and in california three
violent attacks targeted elderly asian
americans in oakland's chinatown actors
daniel wu and daniel day kim offered a
25 thousand dollar reward for
information the suspect was arrested and
is facing criminal charges the national
crime victimization survey found that
violent crimes committed against asian
americans has been rising since 2015. in
new york city asian americans are the
only demographic where victimization
increased from 2008 to 2019 across all
types of crime
the idea is always with all hate crime
investigations to determine
uh was it motivated by hate or not as as
the inspector told us you know once it's
determined factually that there was a
hate motivation that adds to the
penalties
um so no we can't prejudge each incident
we need the facts but that said there is
clearly
a horrible trend right now
disgusting trend in this city and in
this nation
of attacks on asian americans most
horribly what we saw in san francisco
where a man was killed just walking down
the street
no provocation no reason just killed
because he was asian-american
here to discuss the rise in
asian-american hate crimes is defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and co-host terry
austin
guys these increases are not small from
2019 to 2020 america saw dramatic
increases of anti-asian american crimes
200 percent increase in philly in
cleveland 114 percent in la and 833 in
new york city terry thoughts and
reactions to the increase of these hate
crimes
brian you know in my mind there is a
correlation between hate crimes against
asian americans and the rhetoric that we
saw in the trump administration he has
blamed the coronavirus on you know the
chinese population and he's called it
the china virus he's called it the kung
flu virus and these names are very
derogatory and they have an effect on
people when they hear it and when you
have a bully pulpit and you can say
these things you have to be careful what
you say and i also think that the
general rise in white supremacy has also
contributed to the crimes the hate
crimes which are crimes that you you
know
perpetuate against people because of
their race so i think we're seeing a
rise everywhere
gigi why do you think we're seeing these
rising numbers
know terry really hit the nail on the
head you know this trend is disturbing
and disgusting but it's really not
surprising you know we've witnessed the
strongest voices in our country over the
past year
uh degrade and vilify the asian-american
community and when we see other kinds of
hate crimes uh decrease but we see uh
hate crimes against the asian-american
community increase that means we know
that the violent rhetoric surrounding
the asian community is responsible for
inviting more hate crimes against the
asian community and it's a it's a really
big disgrace brian absolutely it's
absolutely disgusting we saw a similar
situation happened to the muslim
american community shortly after 9 11 of
course rhetoric giving to hate hate
leading to crime something that we hope
to never see
in the future thank you both
when we come back new york's attorney
general is looking to change the grand
jury process the case that's making her
speak out after the break
we're back a grand jury's decision to
not indict officers of murdering a
mentally distraught man in police
restraints is putting a renewed
spotlight on the grand jury process
body cam footage shows rochester new
york police officers putting a hood on a
man's head and shoving his face into the
ground naked and handcuffed the shocking
footage captured the moments which
ultimately led to the death of daniel
prude prude's family says it was said
that prue died of an overdose in police
custody and didn't see the video of the
march incident until late august the
medical examiner's office ruled that
asphyxia excited delirium and pcp
intoxication caused prude's death the
manner of death is listed as homicide
is a man in the throes of a mental
health crisis
who was literally crying out for help
the only way that he knew
and his brother joe
he also placed a call for help
he didn't call for the police to come
deal with a law enforcement crisis he
called for
emergency medical professionals to deal
with a mental health crisis
the officers who responded on march 22
knew that mr prude was experiencing this
mental health crisis
and medical experts have recognized it
as excited delirium
a state that can cause individuals to
act
irrationally yet the officers who
ultimately restrained mr prude were
largely unfamiliar with how to handle
this type of medical emergency and while
there was no evidence that the spit hood
placed over mr prude's head
directly contributed to his death
it clearly
added to his stress
and agitation
new york's attorney general's office
presented the case to a grand jury
calling it the strongest case possible
that grand jury decided to not vote to
move forward on charges
the criminal justice system
has frustrated efforts to hold law
enforcement officers accountable
the unjustified killing of unarmed
african americans
the system too often allows officers to
use deadly force
unnecessarily and without consequence
and that is a system that at its core
is broken
there can be no accountability without
transparency
and so i once again call for grand jury
reform
grand jury secrecy rules should be
relaxed the public deserves to know what
transpired behind closed doors
the current secrecy laws are just out of
date
anachronistic in an effort to provide
maximum transparency my office is
proactively releasing a comprehensive
report about mr prude's death including
a minute
by minute
account of the events
on march 22 and march 23 2020
back one last time for legal analysis is
gigi gonzalez and terry austin gigi as
low as the standard is for a grand jury
to indict i'm kind of surprised they
didn't get the indictment here what do
you expect to see when or if the
testimony is released
you know i'm surprised by that too i'm
hoping to see that the grand jury heard
every piece of evidence and was
instructed properly and i think that's
what's going to happen here attorney
general james has been very forthright
about her position in regards to grand
juries and
her hope to see uh mr prude get justice
in this case uh so it ends the fact that
she released a
post non-indictment report and asked the
judge to release the testimony just
shows that uh we're going to see that
attorney general did everything she
could to secure an indictment here
terry let me be devil's advocate for a
moment here should the testimony be
released i get it grand juror comes out
says we were lied to something was wrong
let's let's show everyone the grand jury
process let's do it i'm all for it but
it seems like we're just doing this
because the attorney general wants it is
that a precedent that we should be
moving forward on
well i think it should be released and
whether or not our attorney general
wants it to be released i think in this
case it needs to we need to answer
questions like was all the evidence
presented was it presented fairly were
the correct charges pursued and i think
if the answers to all of those questions
happens to be yes then maybe we actually
need to change the law as it relates to
the reasonable use of force here
all right gigi and terry thank you and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america